the Home Office is notorious for
bringing illustrious careers to abrupt
ends but the pressures that exist behind
its closed doors have never prompted a
resignation quite like this in the last
10 days I had been the target of a
vicious and orchestrated briefing
campaign it has been alleged that I have
briefed the media against the Home
Secretary this along with many other
claims is completely false
the Home Secretary categorically denied
any involvement in this campaign to the
Cabinet Office
I regret I do not believe her an
accusation that the Home Secretary had
lied less than a week after a joint
statement was issued on behalf of both
pretty battalions to Philip Ratnam
denying their working relationship had
broken down in his statement sir Philip
also said that he had turned down a
financial settlement offer from the Home
Office and that he intends to take legal
action for what he describes as
constructive dismissal if this were to
end up in the courts it could be deeply
uncomfortable for the government not
least because any tribunal would likely
require scrutiny under oath of the
complaints of Philip claimed he received
about the Home Secretary shouting
swearing and belittling staff no
statement was issued by the Home
Secretary today but last week ministers
entirely rejected claims she was a bully
yes she's demanding but in that role you
have to be but the extraordinary
departure of the former permanent
secretary has now prompted demands for a
full investigation this is a shocking
level of breakdown at the very top of
one of the most important government
departments which has to deal with the
rising violent crime or important
counter-terror work and that's why I
think it's so important that the Prime
Minister and the cabinet secretary don't
just let this drift cabinet secretary
Sir Mark said while said he'd accepted
sir Philips resignation with deep regret
but insisted the work of the Home Office
would continue uninterrupted but there
will now be a keen focus on how the head
of the civil service responds Sir Philip
clearly thought that the issues were so
grave that
needed to resign in this way and he
suggests in his letter that it was in
part to protect other civil servants I
think there is now an urgent need and
force' mark said more the cabinet
secretary to sit down with the Prime
Minister and have it a robust and very
very clear conversation about what's
happened here trade union officials have
claimed the resignation is linked to
what they see as a confrontational
campaign against the civil service led
by the Prime Minister's most senior
adviser Dominic Cummings but there is no
sign that Boris Johnson is doing
anything other than standing by mr.
Cummings and indeed the Home Secretary
herself Tom Rainer Sky News Westminster